tenemos una matriz de 2 x 2 y sus
elementos son am b
ya tenemos mucha práctica en la
obtención de determinantes en una matriz
como stem el determinante de a que es lo
mismo que calcular el determinante de a
b c d esto será igual a a por de menos b
por c ahora qué pasa si multiplicamos
una fila de esta matriz por una
constante que le pasará al determinante
bueno intentémoslo el determinante de la
matriz original a b c d sólo estoy
reescribiendo lo que teníamos sabemos
que este determinante es a de menos bs
ahora imagina que multiplicó la primera
fila por una constante acá como
cambiaría el determinante bueno ahora en
lugar de tener esta app
tendremos captura y en esta vez en lugar
de tener sólo una vez ahora tendremos
cada orden por lo tanto esto será acá
que multiplica a a d veces lo cual es lo
mismo que acá por nuestro determinante
original de la matriz am
esto parece bastante interesante te
encargo que observes que al poner la
constante en la segunda fila en lugar de
ponerla en la primera fila obtienes
exactamente lo mismo
ahora vamos a verificar qué es lo que
pasa si multiplicamos ambas columnas por
la constante k cómo cambia el
determinante bueno esta vez tengo acá
por am por k por d por lo tanto aquí
tendría una cara apretada menos y
después tendríamos queda por ver por acá
por cm por lo tanto esto es lo mismo si
factor izamos una cara cuadrada que acá
cuadrada por el determinante de la
matriz a esto se puede extender a una
propiedad general si tengo una matriz a
adn por n
entonces el determinante de cada vez es
la matriz a tn por n el determinante de
multiplicar una constante por la matriz
completa es decir voy a multiplicar la
constante por todas las filas de la
matriz
por todos sus elementos bueno este
determinante será pausa el vídeo y
piensa si puedes intuir el resultado de
esta fórmula general podemos pensar que
las respuestas acá por el determinante
de a pero recuerda que eso es lo que
obtendríamos si sólo multiplicó a una
fila o una columna por acá se multiplicó
la matriz entera por camps entonces este
determinante será la constante k elevada
a la potencia n por el determinante de
la matriz a de n por n te encargo que
compruebes que esto tiene sentido en una
matriz de 3 por 3 y también se puede
demostrar de manera general que pasan en
el caso de una matriz de n por n eso no
lo haré por ahora ya que el objetivo de
este vídeo es que te quedes con esta
idea hasta la próxima